foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
there were a lot of people doing a lot
of great work last night covering this
and one is the sports director for Fox
19 Joe danaman who joins us now Joe
thanks for joining us I know you're
short on sleep but where were you when
uh this tackle took place so then I was
on the sideline near the end zone and
when the tackle took place you mentioned
it the medical staffs were the two teams
that was what was most alarming to me
was the urgency with what they hit the
field and uh you know we often see
injuries on the field but you don't see
this kind of urgency from medical staffs
the way they ran to Demar the way they
ripped open the medical equipment the
way they started working on him
immediately from my vantage point I
could see them doing chest compressions
and at that point that's when you
started to see the teams gather around
him and you started to lose your Vantage
Point to that but they also administered
an AED they shocked him twice on the
field you talked about the process the
NFL has and having aeds on on the field
there and that was part of the process
they used but what was striking to me
was the reaction from the players and
look whenever we see someone with a head
injury or a spinal injury in the NFL and
that's part of the game we understand
that we wait for some kind of positivity
from the player or the players around
them maybe a thumbs up we're all waiting
for that kind of moment when you saw
players turn away and cover their face
with their jerseys or cover their face
with their hands you knew right then
this was different and something we had
never experienced before yeah I'd
mentioned that having been on the
sidelines for a variety of things I
usually look at the Players the players
will tell you if a player is seriously
hurt and that's when I knew that you
know this was really really serious when
did you start to get a sense of what was
going to happen with the game itself
once they told the teams to go inside
and they had not yet postponed at that
point they had suspended it you could
see the reaction from the players that
this was not a team equipped emotionally
to go back on a field and play a
football game within a few minutes and
to kind of give you an idea what was
happening is the Players walked back
into the tunnel Dan towards their locker
room they could still see the ambulance
that was waiting in the parking lot
because they were waiting for a demar's
mother to make it down from the stands
to ride with him to the University of
Cincinnati Medical Center so they could
still see the ambulance he was in at the
end of the tunnel before it left and you
could just tell from the looks on the
faces and the emotion from the players
they were not going to play this game
within a matter of minutes Zach Taylor
the Bengals head coach came over to
their locker room to meet with Sean
McDermott the referees were there and we
had a good clue then that there was no
way they were playing this game at that
point did you have any idea that who was
making this decision because there's
conflicting reports of the teams were
told you got five minutes Joe Buck said
this I think four times on the broadcast
the NFL Troy Vincent said no that was
not the case I didn't know what role the
coaches the captains played in this uh
can you sort any of that out for us as
far as what the NFL and their
involvement I can't I can tell you the
referees Zach Taylor Sean McDermott and
members of the front office with the
Buffalo Bills were outside of the Bill's
Locker Room discussing this pretty
quickly after the announcement of the
suspension of the game so to me that was
a signal that they were there amongst
each other talking about this Sean
McDermott didn't last long in that
meeting he was out there very briefly
and then he went back inside the locker
room to be with his team but Zach Taylor
other members of the Bengals coaching
staff were there with the referees
discussing obviously deciding to
postpone this game but as far as the
NFL's involvement in it from where I was
in my vantage point I I don't know how
much involvement they had at that point
how much confusion was going on
not much quite honestly um because um
there was
to me the confusion was why why was the
ambulance still on the parking lot look
we had the player on the field for for
nine minutes with the chest compressions
and the AED and the players having to
watch this and a lot of times Daniel C
guys go up to a player as they're
leaving a field or or being lifted into
an ambulance or lifted up onto a stretch
or go up there and tap them and dab him
up and make sure he's okay and they know
they have his support those guys were
told to stay back so that was different
right there but once they'd announced it
that the suspension of the game was
going to happen it was very organized
the guys went back into the locker room
both teams stayed in their locker rooms
for a long time it wasn't until they
announced the actual postponement of the
game that we saw some of the Bengals
players then make their way from the
Bengals locker room down to the Bill's
Locker Room that included team captains
that included Joe burrow who made his
way to the Bill's Locker Room in fact we
saw Josh Allen then go to the Bengals
locker room as well to meet with some of
their players because the bill stayed in
Cincinnati at paid for stadium for a
long time I mean this happened in the
nine o'clock hour they didn't leave
didn't leave the stadium until 12 30. so
those guys were there for a long time
just to be around each other to comfort
each other in any way they could and I
think you see this fraternity of
football players right where look I'm
sure there are Bengals players who
played with him at some point played
against him or or with him at some point
in the pre-draft process so I'm sure a
lot of guys in the bank was locker room
knew him not only the bills were feeling
this but the Bengals players as well any
sense of how many Buffalo Bills players
went to the hospital
no I know Stefan Diggs was the one
player that was the high profile player
that did go there as far as outside of
him I don't know of other players that
went to the hospital any idea uh or the
Bengals have any idea of an update on
what's going to happen uh with the
possibility of playing this game or how
does it end
yeah that's a great question that's
something right now that I've been told
by the team will be handled by the
league at this point
um obviously it's a very unique
situation because we all understood and
that's the weird part about this Dan was
this was supposed to be the Showcase of
everything that's going great right here
in Cincinnati now with this football
team playing great football the Bills
being the team that the Bengals are
competing with trying to get that number
one seed so you have this joy and
excitement of what's happening on Monday
Night Football and then this happens and
it's this emotional dichotomy of of joy
and excitement to sadness and curiosity
of what's happening but as far as what's
going to happen with the game at this
point we have not been given any
information from the Cincinnati Bengals
what they're going to do with this game
against the bills do you think the
Bengals expect the Bengals will show up
for practice where they or it was
Tuesday going to be an off day for them
Tuesday is a dark day for the Bengals
they they don't show up for practice
today there was no scheduled media
availability today they were supposed to
be back in the building tomorrow for
practice for normal media availability
that will be released later today if
they're going to change that what
they're going to do because
um look we obviously all are curious and
worried and hopeful for Demar but at
some point we we have to figure out
what's going to happen when the rest of
this football season because there's a
lot of
stuff on the line here with the Bengals
and the bills and the Chiefs and the AFC
and and going forward I just I don't
know how how these guys handle this
emotionally I'll share another anecdote
with you Dan we were outside of the
Bengals locker room they moved all the
media out of the tunnels and away from
the Locking room there is a second exit
from the Bengals locker room and we
could see Bengals wide receiver T
Higgins if you remember he was involved
with the play he caught the pass he was
the guy that Hamlin was trying to tackle
when he fell to the ground popped up and
collapsed and and T's mom was there and
T's mom was waiting for him outside of
the locker room they shared an emotional
moment he walked off so again you know
it's not just the bills dealing with
this that there are there are Bengals
players who have never seen anything
like this before trying to deal with it
as well great job Joe thank you
you're welcome no problem Joe danaman
Sports director for Fox 19 in uh
Cincinnati